un nouveau visage du viaduc de guville
vieux de 50 ans depuis 2016 l'autoroute
à 13 faitpau neuve un chantier
titanesque qui a duré 7 ans cette année
durant lesquelles les deux viaduces
d'origine ont été entièrement rénovés
mais pas que par exemple on a rajouté
des canivaux d'assaainissement qui
n'existaient pas pour récupérer et
traiter l'eau qui tombe sur les viaducs
on a entièrement renouveler la chaussée
c'estd qu'on a enlevé on a remis de
l'étanchéité remis une nouvelle chaussée
et puis on a enfin renforcé l'ouvrage
avec de la fibre de carbone pour lui
permettre de repartir pour les 50 années
à venir mais pour y arrivé arcadis
maître d'œuf du chantier et le
concessionnaire SAPN filiale du groupe
SANEF ont dû construire un troisème
vieduc entre 2016 et 2019 avant de
s'attaquer à la rénovation des deux
vieducs existants c'était de construire
un troisième ouvrage sur lequel nous
sommes en ce moment pour permettre en
fait de pouvoir fermer un des deux
viaduces et de réaliser les travaux sans
trop gêner les clients rouvert depuis le
13 septembre 2023 les 120000 conducteurs
quotidiens peuvent maintenant bénéficier
de SEP voies de circulation au lieu de 6
d'une séparation des voies de
circulation entre les véhicules légers
et les poids lourds depuis Paris et
d'une bande d'arrêt d'urgence pour
chaque viaduc mais pour entièrement
mettre à œuf l'autoroute à 13 le groupe
SANEF ne s'arrête pas là 11 km de
chaussée entre le viaduc de Guerville et
les changeurs de bonière vont être
rénovés le but de ces travaux euh c'est
euh de redonner pour au moins 20 ou 30
ans des caractéristiques structurelle
d'une chaussée neuve et au passage on
refait aussi la couche de surface dont
la durée de vie sera un petit peu moins
longue mais qui donc retrouvera elle
aussi des caractéristiques toutes neuves
de confort et d'adhérence pour le
confort et la sécurité des clients de
l'autoroute pour ces travaux le groupe
SANEF a investi près de 12 millions
d'euros et mobilisé 60 à 100 personnes
par face de chantier le tout réalisé de
nuit pour gêner le moins possible les
automobilistes mais l'autre défi de ces
travaux c'est de limiter le plus
possible son impact environnemental ce
qui veut dire utiliser le moins possible
de bitume et de béton bitumineux pour ça
on opte pour une solution de
renforcement innovante avec un système
de géogrille qui permet de ne faire
qu'une seule couche de renforcement
structurel un deuxième levier pour
limiter l'impact environnemental de ce
chantier c'est d'optimiser le recyclage
et on arrive à recycler sur la plupart
de ce chantier 40 % de l'ancienne
chaussée qui est raboté et donc
réutilisé à 40 % dans la nouvelle
chaussée qui est mise en œuvre juste
après un système innovant qui réduit
aussi la durée du chantier donc on
arrive à faire entre 800 m et 1 km
chaque semaine en travaillant uniquement
la nuit euh avec une fermeture ou des
basculements d'autoroute entre 22h et 5h
ces travaux qui font partie de la
deuxème phase de rénovation des
chaussées de la 13 devrait se finir fin
novembre 2023 prochaine étape de
rénovation la mise en place du flux
libre des barrières de péage en